you know i'm walking up to the truck
stop and i was getting fuel i wanted to
get some coffee so
i walk in and this big guy opens up the
door for me and he's like nice tits
and i looked over at him and i was like
nice tits
and i walked in he had bigger boobs than
i did
he had some freaking heaters on him huh
yeah i have to do that
to like i'm walking out with hot dogs
and this guy's like you want to come in
and see my hot dog i got a hot dog for
you
and i was like well you shut the hell up
i said i'm gonna go eat my lunch before
i throw up on it
and then just went to my truck and ate
my hot dogs yeah
then that part of it's obviously that's
messed up but at the same time part of
it is kind of funny
yeah it is funny and you people watch a
lot too when especially when you're
sitting you've got 10 hour break
you can drive 14 hours 11 of that's
driving three hours is
on duty not driving okay so what does
that mean take me through some of that
so
so the rule is you can drive for how
long 11 hours
11 hours straight no no yeah you can
drive
up to eight but before the h you have to
take a 30 minute break
okay before they once you took your 30
minute break it'll reset it
to where that you've got extra time to
drive and you usually approximately have
maybe
four to five more to drive and you're
done and it can't total any more than
14.
that's on duty not driving is usually
like
fueling washing your truck windshield
off or any repairs that might be needed
that's on duty okay and so you'll take
so you might drive seven hours
and there's five hours and then say okay
i'm gonna take my half hour break yes
i'm gonna take a half hour break now yes
and then how much more can you drive for
you take another break
uh you'll only be allowed maybe five
maybe six more just depends on
you know how you run before and once
once that happens you have to take a
10-hour break
okay so i'm just gonna just because i'm
not good at a lot so i'm gonna ask again
just so out of 14 hours
you can only drive 11 of them right and
then after that 14-hour space
right you have to take a 10-hour break
yes okay so within 14 hours you need to
take three hours break
yes total total and then after that you
you need to take a 10 hour break yes
okay and do you is that good because you
you're glad to have the breaks or is it
bad because you're trying to make time
no when you take your 30 minute break
that's it's actually
you know you can break any time you want
actually
like sometimes i'll stop after i've
drove about four hours
and i'll take a 15 minute break just to
stretch my legs get out
walk you know maybe get a drink or pee
and then get back in the truck you drive
another say
three and a half more hours before the
eight's up and i'll take a 30. that's
when i'll have my lunch
or i'll play a video game on my phone or
just
you know just walk around anything oh
because before eight hours you have to
also take a break
yeah yeah you have to okay that's the
law required it has to be a 30 minute
break
okay so with that within every 14 hours
you can only drive 11
right and every eight hours you have to
take a break yes
i got it yes then once you pull over for
the night
and it's time to take your 10-hour break
you can rest area or truck stop there's
times when
i've pulled over onto a ramp you know as
you're getting
back on the interstate that way when i
wake up i can just
take off keep it and go yeah a lot of
times yeah you will see trucks that are
just right there on the side i always
wonder what's going on
i usually thought sex or drugs
no not for me i'll uh pull my curtains i
got the truck running up to set my
temperature where i want it
you know especially like in i like the
ac on so i'll dim all my lights inside
and make sure my doors are locked and
depending on the area sometimes i'll
actually like use my seat belt
latch it over the door handle and lock
it so that it can't you can't open the
door no matter what you do
yeah and then once that you get back
here pull the curtain
pull back my covers i got my microwave i
got a keurig for coffee
i got a tv set up in there put dvds in
it or i've got a cord that hooks up to
my
iphone and i watch movies oh wow yeah i
got home movies
in a little cabinet that i can watch and
i'll sit back here and eat
you know smoke cigarette watch tv and
set my alarm go to bed
that's it and so now are there times
that you will
no so i'm guessing that your truck has a
a facility of space in there you can get
some rest oh yeah
plenty it's actually got uh bunk beds in
there okay
the bottom one is uh uh like a full to
twin
can you pull that up for us on
freightliner cabin or what would we
bring up you think
we oh just uh inside cap freightliner
and uh look up maybe bunk or sleeper
berth
that actually would be better look up
sleeper berth
and it'll show you this because you got
a bed up the top that you can fold back
against the wall
if you're not using it so it leaves that
space open for you
or you could pull it down if you had
somebody with you and you stop you
let them hang out up there and sleep but
you don't put them up there while you're
driving
right because they could actually fall
out yeah that sounds a little risky now
which one of these do you think seems
like yours here ginger
okay that's see the bed with the red
yeah that's kind of it's kind of like
that
inside okay because it's got the bunk
beds
and it's got cabinet space and then i've
got a spot for
the microwave refrigerators right
underneath of it
oh yeah yeah it's it's nice you got
enough room that's where i actually
learned to
dance for his uh wedding i was in my
truck
really yeah i couldn't be with him to me
and him to learn the dance together
so i practiced inside of my truck so
jeff sent you a video and showed you how
to do it well
it was part of the movie uh pulp fiction
oh wow
where john travolta and uh uh what's her
name
uh what's her name [ __ ] karen she was it
was uh
yeah uma thurman thurman yeah when they
danced together
in that restaurant they were at that's
what made him mother and son for his
wedding
yeah so you learned that in your tricks
you could stand up and learn that oh
yeah there's enough room in that cab to
do that
and so now there's a lot of oh yeah
there it is right there that's cool
that's awesome and i was learning that
in the truck because most of it is
just a twist so you're not flailing
yourself all over the place you know you
could get hurt in there
yeah good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah